l'orgasme
vous êtes prêts
eh bien figurez-vous que il n'y a aucune
raison pour que moi je vous parle de
l'orgasme féminin n'ont aucune raison
dans mon parcours jusqu'au jour il y a
quelques années d'ici où j'ai eu un
projet littéraire j'ai décidé d'écrire
un recueil de nouvelles consacrées aux
premières émotions érotique est
amoureuse de la petite enfance
je voulais parler de ces histoires qu'on
a dans la cour de récréation
alors je suis parti à la pêche aux
histoires dans mon entourage proche
on approche et à ma grande surprise mes
interlocuteurs mon livre est beaucoup
plus que prévu à peu près toute leur vie
sexuelle
et là je suis tombé des nues sur un
point précis c'était la difficulté du
parcours des femmes pour atteindre le
plaisir sexuel
j'ai découvert que dans mon entourage il
y avait des femmes qui n'avaient encore
jamais eu d'orgasme
il y avait des femmes qui en avait seul
mais jamais en couple il y avait des
femmes qui en avait en couple mais ça
avait pris trois ans où ça avait pris 10
partenaires
il y avait des femmes qui avaient des
orgasmes avec hole mais qui n'en avaient
pas avec jacques ou à jack et pas avec
paul et qui ne comprenaient pas et puis
le plus étonnant de tous et elle est
femme qui ne savait pas si elle en avait
eu ou pas
bon alors là j'étais incroyablement
perplexe c'est quoi ce micmac expliquez
moi je personne pouvait m'expliquer
alors j'ai décidé de chercher
l'explication toute seule je suis parti
dans une enquête sur la question de
l'orgasme féminin ça finalement pris
plusieurs années et voilà pourquoi je
suis là et je me propose de vous
raconter quelques uns des résultats
importants
j'ai procédé en trois temps je vais vous
parler du corps je vais vous parler des
blocages qui nous plombe
et je vais vous parler des libertés qui
s'ouvre à nous alors le corps ben c'est
évidemment important de l'orgasme ça
passe par le corps en général
alors il faut faire un point sur
l'anatomie l'anatomie sexuelle détaillée
des femmes
eh bien elle est mal connue croyez moi
mais il ya quand même un acteur sur
lequel tout le monde est d'accord c'est
le célèbre clitoris
bien sûr ous avez peut-être où il se
trouve
enfin sans doute parce qu'aujourd'hui
80% des français savent que cette petite
chose à fleurs tout en haut de la vulve
et est ce que vous savez quelle forme et
quelle taille
il a ça c'est plus compliqué je vous
invite à faire l'exercice fermer les
yeux trois secondes et essayez de vous
représenter mentalement le contour de
cet organe ok chacun a son idée vous
allez pouvoir vérifier puisque puisque
la forme exacte du clitoris
la voici ah ben ça c'est un vaisseau
spatial s'est dessiné par un auteur de
science-fiction le la zone rouge c'est
ce que tout le monde connaît c'est le
gland du clitoris ce qui affleure à
l'extérieur tout le reste est intérieure
on a un coût dont on a un trou on a une
fourche d'où se sépare de jambes mince
qui court le long des eaux du pubis et
on a deux bulles d'eau du qui longe les
grandes lèvres et le tout fait plus de
dix centimètres alors en dessous en gris
vous avez l'ouverture du vagin qui est
surmonté de l'ouverture de l'urètre
si vous n'étiez pas entièrement
conscient de cette chose c'est un peu
normal c'est connu depuis peu en fait on
a publié l'anatomie interne complète du
clitoris en 1981 18 c'est une urologue
australienne qui a fait cette
publication c'est quand même trente ans
après la découverte de la lune non
surprenant mais alors pourquoi le
clitoris at-il cette allure un peu un
peu incroyable
en fait il ya une explication c'est le
frère jumeau du pénis c'est le même
organe déployer autrement pour céder on
peut on peut penser en termes d'un
canapé lit ça vous dit quelque chose
une structure unique vous la déployer
souhaite comme canapé soit comme l'i et
bien ici
pendant trois mois les trois premiers
mois de la gestation on a une structure
unique identique pour les deux sexes et
d'ailleurs ils ressemblent à ceux ci ce
que vous voyez au centre du schéma c'est
un un petit organe
génitales qui comprend un bulbe en jaune
une fente en noir de bourrelets en rose
et s'est entouré de tissu plissé en rose
clair et ce n'est qu'au troisième mois
au bout du troisième mois qu'un signal
hormonal va induire une divergence
à gauche on va se déployer façon pénis
et à droite on va se déployer façon
clitoris et puis à ce moment là on bouge
plus un hangar de soi de son lit soit
son canapé fut question de changer mais
ce qui est important c'est que ils sont
formés exactement du même matériau ça
veut dire qu'ils ont les mêmes
caractéristiques en termes de
sensibilité des milliers de terminaisons
nerveuses des deux côtés ils ont aussi
les mêmes caractéristiques est patente
au niveau de l'élasticité oui le
clitoris entre en érection lors de
l'excitation sexuelle
oui ça arrive aussi inconsciemment
toutes les nuits et au petit matin
exactement comme chez les hommes
et oui ça prend des proportions
impressionnantes c'est un volume
quasiment équivalent à celui du pénis en
érection
et le vagin dans tout ça le vagin c'est
encore plein de mystère mais en tout cas
à première vue ça ne participe pas à
cette architecture excitables le vagin
ça sert à autre chose c'est une voie de
passage dans les deux sens
ça n'a pas d'innovation sensorielle de
type tactile et donc
c'est autre chose mais il faut bien
tenir compte de la réalité du vécu
en fait entre 30 et 50 % des femmes
déclarent qu'elles ont un point de
sensibilité particulière dans le vagin
et c'est souvent dans la paroi
supérieure du vagin c'est ce qu'on a
appelé le point g le point g a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre on l'a cherché
partout on n'a rien trouvé ça n'existe
pas en termes d'organes ou d'entités
anatomique distinctes mais ce qu'on
pense aujourd'hui c'est que le vagin en
fête permet de stimuler le clitoris par
l'intérieur puisque vous voyez bien que
le clitoris est à cheval sur le machin
et j'en profite pour préciser que dans
ce schéma le clitoris est en érection il
est gonflé gorgés de sang s'ils étaient
au repos où ils seraient tous faim comme
comme des petites chaussettes qui
pendent mais en élection il est bien
gonflés et le vagin est juste en dessous
et alors ce qu'on a remarqué en faisant
de l'échographie dynamique du clitoris
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire une
échographie pendant le rapport sexuel si
si c'est possible et il ya des
chercheurs qui s'attelle à ce genre de
chose quand on fait ça on remarque que
le clitoris se gorge à 200
d'autre part ils s'abaissent sur sa
monture un peu comme un motard qui se
couche sur sa moto dans un virage
ici en plus à ce moment le vagin est
rempli par une présence on va dire
amicale
il se passe ce si c'est à dire que le
vagin et dilatés et il fait appuyé vers
le haut sur l'urètre mais aussi sur la
fourche du clitoris et comme le clitoris
est extrêmement sensible
il entend le message à travers la paroi
en tout cas si la stimulation est
vraiment spécifique et ça nous mène à
quoi ça nous mène à l'organe fait que
l'orgasme l'orgasme
c'est lorsque le neures pudans talent
celui qui relie le clitoris au cerveau
reçoit une quantité de stimulation
suffisante
il va déclencher un réflexe du système
nerveux autonome réflexe ça veut dire
inconscient involontaire en fait comme
quand vous éternuez mais sauf que
l'orgasme c'est autre chose c'est des
contractions dans la zone génitale
c'est des tas de choses dans le corps
des tas de choses dans le cerveau et
bien sûr cette sensation de plaisir
intense
j'espère que vous voyez un peu de quoi
je parle et qui dit orgasme pardon qui
dit réflexe chez les humains doit parler
aussi du mental
nous avons cette particularité le
réflexe est produit par un stimulus il
peut aussi être produit par le mental il
ya un exemple trivial vous le connaissez
sans doute c'est que si vous mettez un
citron sur votre langue vous allez
immédiatement saliver c'est un réflexe
mais si vous pensez un citron vous le
visualiser bien vous voulez déposer sur
votre langue en pensez et immédiatement
vous allez saliver aussi donc vous avez
provoqué le réflexe au moyen du mental
c'est une suggestion donc le stimuli le
stimulus pardon et le
le mental vont avoir leur effet en même
temps ça peut être se combiner dans le
bon sens où ça peut malheureusement se
contrarier
alors parlons du stimulus d'abord
puisque c'est la première chose qui
provoque le réflexe le stimulus il doit
être adapté et la meilleure façon de
provoquer un orgasme maintenant qu'on a
toute cette anatomie c'est c'est connu
il faut stimuler le gland du clitoris ou
bien il faut stimuler la fourche du
clitoris éventuellement par l'intérieur
mais ça il vaut mieux avoir un réflexe à
un stimulus précis donc une pression ou
un frottement et puis il ya une
troisième phase ont éventuellement c'est
la pénétration mais alors il faut
vraiment quelque chose qui soit adaptée
et toute pénétration de ne permet pas
d'obtenir un orgasme les femmes le
savent bien en général il faut ajouter
une stimulation du clitoris externe ou
alors il faut une stimulation
particulière qu'ils soient dirigés par
la femme en suivant ses sensations et
puis le plus compliqué dans tout ça
c'est que pour ce qu'il ya du vagin il
peut y avoir probablement d'autres
sensations qui ne sont pas dues aux
nerfs sensorielle mais qui sont dus à
des nerfs plus profond
qui sont qui sont malheureusement mal
connue en fait la science n'a rien à
dire à ce stade sur ce qui peut se
passer au fond du vagin
c'est no man's land nada nous ne savons
rien il faudra attendre peut-être qu'on
ait atterri sur jupiter pour trouver le
fin mot de ce qui se passe au fond du
vagin
en attendant c'est sûrement quand les
femmes des pilotes le rapport sexuel que
l on le plus de chance de découvrir ce
qui s'y passe d'après ce qu'elles
ressentent et malheureusement c'est pas
ça qui se passe dans les rapports
sexuels dans dans les couples en général
ce qui se passe le plus souvent c'est
que c'est andres au centre et ça veut
dire ça vise à provoquer les accusations
mais quand c'est la femme qui dirige le
rapport sexuel elle cherche à provoquer
quoi l'éjaculation est l'écart
orgasmique toujours très important et on
est véritablement dans un blocage donc
il faut parler de ce blocage
ce blocage c'est d'abord un héritage
historique majeur parce que la sexualité
en de recentrer c'est le fait des
sociétés phallocratique qui
malheureusement le sont presque tout et
qui vise qui ont pour caractéristique de
d'ignorer ou de ou de carrément
supprimer la libido des femmes et de la
remplacer par un code de conduite qui
est réputé normal et qui aboutit à
l'orgasme masculin
je vais rappeler une seule chose à ce
sujet c'est que au 19e siècle en europe
les femmes qui étaient déclarés
hystérique donc tout anormal était en
général les femmes qui souffraient d'une
frustration sexuelle grave et elle
risque fort d'être excisées excisées ça
veut dire on coupe où on brûle au fer
rouge le clitoris ça se passait à paris
ça se passait à londres ça se passait en
allemagne couramment oublions ça les
choses ont changé à partir des années 50
avec des chercheurs avec qui ont
débouché sur la libération sexuelle
aujourd'hui le
la sexualité des femmes va mieux sauf
sur un point c'est l'accès à l'orgasme
c'est toujours très difficile dans les
enquêtes dans nos pays ca s'établit
autour de 45 % le nombre de femmes qui
disent avoir accès à l'orgasme souvent
ou très souvent lors des rapports
sexuels
ça veut dire moins de la moitié par
contre si on parle de masturbation et
bien ce chiffre monte à plus de 80%
c'est quand même étrange et le temps
moyen pour obtenir cet orgasme
masturbation il est de 4 minutes wc le
même que celui des hommes
en fait les femmes elles savent très
bien comment ça fonctionne et ça
fonctionne très bien
simplement cette connaissance ne
s'exporte pas vers la sexualité en
couple les refoulements sont toujours là
ils sont dus à tout ce bagage historique
que je vous ai dit mais aussi à des
choses plus plus moderne des travers
plus moderne je pense à la volonté de
performance à la volonté de contrôler et
aussi au souci de l'image de soi qui est
tellement présent dans les médias dans
les magazines je vous donne deux indices
à ce sujet dans une enquête on demande
aux femmes quels sont les obstacles qui
vous empêche d'arriver à l'orgasme en
présence de votre partenaire et bien la
réponse qui vient le plus souvent c'est
la peur de faire des grimaces
autre indice dans une grande étude chez
des étudiants
on constate que les comportements sont
beaucoup plus variés qu'avant mais il
reste un gros problème c'est l'accès à
l'orgasme pour les filles il est
désastreux il est de 10% lors du premier
rendez-vous si ça devienne relation
stable à long terme ça va monter à 68%
qui l'a elle par contre un meilleur
chiffre qu'avant et bien la réponse
allait dans les enquêtes on demande
comment ils conçoivent le rapport sexuel
les garçons en deux attitudes ou bien
ils conçoivent que c'était un coup d'un
soir et ils vont pas se fouler ils vont
juste y aller pour eux point barre ou
bien et se disent je veux la revoir
cette fille j'aimerais bien que ça ma
petite amie est là une autre langue
s'allume ils vont faire ce qu'ils
pensent tout ce qui vous est ce qu'elle
demande pour que ça marche pour elle
aussi
par contre les filles quand on leur pose
la question elles disent quelle que soit
la situation si c'est un coup d'un soir
ou si c'est une relation genre prince
charmant elles vont dire moi je fais
tout pour qu'ils jouissent un mec parce
que c'est important d'être un bon coup
voilà donc les filles ou bien le pinceau
plaisir de l'homme
ou bien elle plante elle pense au regard
de l'homme et dans les deux cas elle
vend ce pas elle est donc
le blocage persiste c'est à dire que les
les femmes au lieu un interlocuteur m'a
dit cette formule qui résume tout une
femme qui pense aux plaisirs de l'homme
elle ne s'abandonnent pas elle travaille
et ben oui elle travaille ça veut dire
que son mental est entièrement dans le
mauvais sens il est dans le sens
contraire à l'excitation il est dans
l'inhibition et donc il est temps il est
grand temps de faire la révolution la
révolution c'est aujourd'hui parce qu'on
est libre de le faire et ça ouvre des
libertés la liberté ça passe d'abord par
le fait de savoir que la sexualité elle
n'est pas innée elle doit s'apprendre la
science nous apprendra aussi si vous
habituer un rat un petit rat de
laboratoire à avoir des relations
sexuelles avec une veste je vous assure
qu'on peut aussi faire ça en dans un
labo et bien le jour où vous enlevez la
veste il est incapable d'avoir un
rapport sexuel il est foutu ça ne marche
plus parce qu'il a été conditionné il
faudra plusieurs séances avant que ça
remarche de nouveau et bienvenue aussi
qui avons des blocages nous pouvons les
dépasser si nous sommes d'accord de
réapprendre je pense aux femmes qui ont
appris à jouir d'une seule façon ce qui
est fréquent aux femmes qui ont appris à
ne pas jouir à force de stress et de
mental négatif et bien elles peuvent
débloquer la situation si elle se met en
route et réapprennent autrement le
corollaire c'est que la sexualité est
évolutive ça veut dire que bon le
silence en occupe pas malheureusement
elle s'atrophie mai mais si on s'y
consacre ça va aller mieux de mieux en
mieux et les femmes vivent souvent j'ai
commencé ma vraie vie à 35 ans à 40 ans
à 50 ans sur le plan sexuel
elles ont bougé par paliers et en
les couvrant ont successivement de
nouvelles choses donc si on se met en
route s'ils ont fait ces sept
si on va à l'aventuré on va découvrir
tas de choses formidables
par exemple on va découvrir son moi
érotique qui est de savoir qu'est-ce qui
vous excite et que vous ne savez pas en
fait c'est pas théorique c'est vraiment
de la pratique si vous n'essayez pas
vous ne pouvez pas le savoir et si vous
essayez vous aurez beaucoup de surprises
parce que le mois cognitif on sait
comment ça marche et mon effectif
beaucoup moins mais le moins érotique
c'est vraiment la porte tout au fond du
couloir personne ne se connaît jusque là
l'autre chose qu'on va découvrir c'est
le pouvoir du mental je vous ai dit dans
dans le réflexe il ya du stimulus il ya
du mental et bien le mental est
malheureusement souvent inhibiteur mais
il pourrait au contraire nous aider et
est allé dans le bon sens et pour ça il
faut l'utiliser donc l'imaginaire les
fantasmes c'est très important surtout
chez les femmes pour qui le désire est
une petite plante toute nouvelle
on n'a jamais eu l'occasion de
s'exprimer on n'a jamais eu
l'autorisation
maintenant on peut alors on y va on
utilise le mental et puis il faut se
sortir une fois pour toutes de la tête
l'idée qu'il ya des choses normales et
des choses pas normales
les sexologues en tant que ça à longueur
de journée suis-je normal non ce qui est
normal c'est ce qui vous convient c'est
tout et qui convient à votre partenaire
aussi infos qu'ils soient d'accord
et puis une chose aussi qu'il faut se
sortir de la tête c'est qui a pas de
performance en sexualité
il n'y a pas de quelque chose à réussir
il n'y a pas d'examen et si vous avez
cette impression c'est peut-être que
vous n'êtes pas avec le bon partenaire
parce que là un regard qui juge c'est un
regard qui tue donc on est là pour
s'amuser et ce qui est bon c'est
uniquement ce qui vous met en joie il
n'y a pas d'autres critères alors après
moi je dis la sexualité c'est un terrain
de liberté et je voudrais qu'on aborde
comme on aborde la poésie c'est à dire
en supprimant en jetons
la syntaxe et la grammaire c'est à dire
en se débarrassant de tous ces interdits
ses obligations tout ce qui nous met en
cage
on est là il ya des choses beaucoup plus
importantes qui sont à développer je
veux dire rencontrer l'autre je veux
dire et prouver son corps je veux dire
inventer sa liberté et je veux dire
développer son identité la multiplier en
fait la liberté elle va pas tomber du
ciel
la liberté c'est quelque chose d'
inventer à inventer concrètement jour
après jour je marie tél